hi I'm Albert Hughes and today I'm
breaking down a scene from the
Continental from the world of John Wick
[Music]
Ed
the scene we're looking at right now was
the first scene that we shot for for
several reasons one because I usually
like upfront in the schedule to shoot
something I'm excited about and
something I can get the crew excited
about and I also like to set a tone and
see where the crew and where me are at
it's something that it's not too
difficult that we can shoot and use the
whole day and I love this character of
the adjudicator played by Katie McGrath
it was wonderful she had one tool taken
from her which is the The Mask that's
revealed a little later
um and then her henchman who's played by
Kirk Ward who is actually our showrunner
and writer so that's fun and the way he
was cast was I had concept drawings done
of the Character cartoon concept
drawings I forget who mentioned Amelia
he looks like Kirk and I'm like oh my
God he does look like Kirk and Kirk
actually comes from an acting background
in the 90s and early odds I'm like you
got to do this so then you know I
started developing the looks of the
character the cauliflower ears his
background they both have backstories
the adjudicator and her henchman whose
name is Kaczynski but it's never
referred to in the movie right
um and it's based off a real person's
name
um and there's Simon Juan who's uh
Frankie's partner Winston Scott's
brother stole something very early on in
the series and this is uh his partner
that turned on him
um and now you see what happens when you
cross the high table and the adjudicator
shows up and she adjudicates the people
see the scene and they always ask me
about the location and I see them you'll
be amazed to know that it's like a kind
of an interior or mini mall that's not
in use anymore and a hungry Budapest and
I saw some location photos first and I
go what is this place
because there's this Atrium style
lighting above it that's kind of a
almost like stained glass windowed and
it creates this
um orange glow Over the Hole
space
so I went there and I saw it I'm like
this is amazing it almost feels Masonic
it feels dungeony it feels
medieval it fills a lot of things and
it's very weak in a way that they're
always big on these locations that are
Grand mysterious decadent you know in
our world because we're in the 1970s
we're dealing with a sanitation strike
and a more grimy New York
um and when I saw it and when you see a
location like that it inspires shots
basically
where is it
oh
I'm trying it
swear
you thought you could outsmart the high
table
how foolish of you
I'm telling you the truth
I got paid to do a job now job got
[__] up
that [__] left me die are you
talking about the [__] that you
were paid to betray
the adjudicator in our series is based
on something that was seen in John Wick
3 that's played by a wonderful actress
um who played the adjudicator in that
film and what their job is is that
basically passed down judgment meet up
punishment if you've done something
wrong
um like in film three of the wick series
uh they punished the Larry Fishburne
character and in this series she's the
adjudicator from the 1970s in New York
and you kind of have questions as to why
is she wearing a mask which is revealed
later
um what kind of adjudicator is she does
she follow all the rules or does she
have her own agenda and she's kind of
mysterious in that way you don't quite
know if she's good or bad and she's
trying to extract information out of
Frankie's partner
surprised that I know
I'm aware of what it is you stole
may I ask you how much you got paid to
steal it
40 Grand
keys to the world for a pittance
not that anyone can put a price on it
the value of an artifact that could
topple an organization that predates the
Roman Empire
what I'm sharing with you is very
privileged information
I only share with one kind of person
kind we're about to die
well in the original script the math was
described as a Hungarian smile mask and
I did some research on that in the smile
mask it's like a simple mask with a
little smile on it and it was supposed
to be this very psychological thing it
did to you if you reward and looked
yourself in a mirror in your smile you
feel better about yourself and I said no
this doesn't make any any sense for this
character let's give her something
cooler so so we started working on this
very kind of ceramic like mask and then
I got into the design of what the lips
look like what color the lipstick is on
the mask and it's a cross between Kabuki
and Geisha is what it is I think the
lower lip is uh Geisha the higher lip is
Kabuki and then the whiteness of it also
lends itself to that
um and then it gets into the Wardrobe
and the choice of color for the
character she's always in purple and
there's a hidden meaning behind why
she's in purple it's partly to do it's
inspired by my mother one of her
favorite colors is purple but there's
also deeper meaning to why she likes
purple
um which the fans have to figure that
out
um there's even purple lipstick on her
um and the tricky part again is this
wonderful actress Katie McGrath had to
act with a mask on and her tool was
taken from her the expression of her
lower half which we've all dealt with
because of coping and and you know from
dealing with covid you can barely hear
someone so in actuality when you're
shooting those scenes she's up in the
second story and the actress below and
me we can't hear what she's saying
and I felt so bad that I said let's
shoot her without the mask so she can
perform all the cameras are rolling and
then we'd grab her sound as we shot her
and you know it's learning on the fly
when you do like I'm sure Darth Vader
had the same issues
uh on set when you cover someone's mouth
they can't even move their mouth like
they want you know so
um that was interesting to find out on
your first day
what you want me to do about quarter
Karma nothing
perhaps this rain is finally coming to
an end
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
seeing intros with a Beatdown
um and then exits
with the continued Beatdown with a
little bit of flare and fun he's playing
this disco track that's uh from baccarat
a Spanish disco group and it's such a
ridiculous Trek
um yes sir I can Boogie that my daughter
was playing for me I'd heard the song
before but she was playing for playing
it for me while I was driving in the
truck and the way to work and I'm like
oh my God this would be cool to match
this up with getting out of this scene
because the one thing I wanted to do
with this series was when can not at the
audience say it's okay to have fun you
know this is not um like earlier films
I've done we're dealing with reality
violence right and the wonderful thing
happened at the end of the scene where
I'm with larnelle Stovall the action
coordinator stunt director and we're
working with Kirk the showrunner and the
character in the scene how to punch this
guy how to sell the punches and larnell
comes up with this great idea you should
jump on him you know and continue to
beat him up uh or or no no you should
jump on him and headbutt him and I'm
like oh my God that's crazy let's do
that right and you know it's a guy in a
kilt jumping on another man in the chair
who's chained down and when I saw it the
first take I go Kirk why don't you
scream before you start head butting him
it's odd so he does this scream and this
scene is taking us into another
important scene with Winston Scott and
I'm really a sucker for transition this
scene starts with a transition of a coin
flipping through the air from the
previous scene and the wick fans will
recognize that coin as the adjudicator
coin so they know this is a scene
involving an adjudicator and the scene
exit with that Atrium I mentioned
earlier
of the ceiling and it was a yellow
ceiling and I go Dad how can I so I had
to figure out what the next scene coming
up was it oh he's at a stop light oh
there's always a yellow light and it was
tricky to figure out
but it's also
um admittedly very self-conscious and I
do a lot of self-conscious of
transitions but it's also a way to wink
and Nod at the audience and tell him you
know you're here to have fun as for
season two I haven't heard anything you
usually wait
um they haven't knocked them out my door
uh I think it would be exciting to
finish up the 70s and go into the 80s
especially with these exciting music
scene of the British the new second
British Invasion of Music MTV the MTV
generation and all my favorites from
back then um you know Prince came on
Michael was at his height Duran Duran
you had Adam Ant you had Culture Club
you had I mean all my favorites from the
earlier I mean it would be so much fun
to play with that so yeah we'll see what
happens
[Music]
thank you